en el vídeo anterior comenzamos a
trabajar en el análisis de un circuito r
lc con una alimentación de entrada y las
matemáticas para hacer esto son bastante
complicadas y lo que decidimos hacer es
ver qué pasa si nos limitamos a usar
entradas senoidal es solamente entradas
que lucen como senos y cosenos
continuaremos con la introducción de la
técnica de análisis senoidal y daremos
un vistazo de hacia dónde vamos con esto
cuando ponemos este límite de usar
solamente ondas senoidal es como entrada
tendremos un gran premio al final y el
premio es que las ecuaciones
diferenciales se vuelven álgebra es la
razón por la que hacemos esto lo vuelve
más sencillo como cuando resolvemos los
circuitos de resistencias que usábamos
álgebra solamente y nada de cálculo
vamos a transformar estas ecuaciones
diferenciales en álgebra para poder
transformar este circuito en un problema
algebraico en lugar de usar ecuaciones
significa que podemos usar la ley de
voltajes de kickoff y podemos usar la
ley de corrientes de kickoff podemos
usar el análisis de nodos o tensiones
normales y el método de corrientes de
malla o análisis de malla igual que lo
hicimos para las resistencias y todo
este conjunto de técnicas se aplican
automáticamente a circuitos que tienen
inductores y capacitores de igual manera
que como aprendimos a hacer con las
resistencias para simplificar los
grandemente dibujemos nuevamente el
circuito que teníamos anteriormente aquí
tenemos aquí tenemos el inductor aquí
está la resistencia y aquí está el
capacitor
con bien nos vamos a limitar a usar
solamente senoidal es lo que quiere
decir que la entrada va a lucir algo así
por coseno de omega t más fin si es el
ángulo de fase iii vamos a representar
esto de manera que luzca así lo vamos a
transformar en algo que tenga a en un
ángulo fin este es el símbolo de ángulo
y a esta representación le llamamos
factor y es una forma de escribir
senoidal es si tengo una seguridad que
luce así y es una función del tiempo la
puedo escribir con un factor donde digo
que b es igual a a con un ángulo fi y se
entiende que este término omega t está
cercano otra cosa que vamos a aprender
es cómo transformar un circuito para que
podamos usar el análisis de estado
estacionario senoidal el inductor se
transforma de l a s por l donde s es la
frecuencia natural el rexistro sigue
siendo r en donde lo encontramos y en
donde tengamos un capacitor vamos a
escribir 1 / s por c y de nuevo la
es la frecuencia natural en un siguiente
vídeo vamos a justificar por qué hacemos
esta transformación y lo que significa
el gran premio es que voy a escribir una
ecuación lb acá alrededor de este
circuito y vean lo que sucede es
sorprendente vamos a indicar rápidamente
los signos de los voltajes este es el
voltaje del inductor éste es el de la
resistencia y este es el del capacitor
aquí está el voltaje de entrada con esta
polaridad aún no es obvio pero vamos a
usar sl y 1 / s s como si fueran las
cantidades de las resistencias en la ley
de ohm vean cómo ocurre voy a escribir
la bbk de ese circuito y lo que obtengo
es
es igual al voltaje a través del
inductor más el de la resistencia más el
del capacitor y lo puedo escribir así s
l x y más r por jim más 1 / s por c por
iu y si escribimos esto de nuevo queda
como ven igual ahí que multiplica a sl
más r más 1 entre s
esta es una aplicación directa de la ley
de kirk of ahora si vemos esta expresión
nos damos cuenta de que es la ecuación
característica de este circuito usando
la transformación de estos componentes y
lo que haremos a continuación es ver un
nuevo concepto puedo escribir esta
ecuación como ven entre y dividimos
entre ambos lados de la ecuación y esto
va a ser igual a ese por el más r más
uno entre s por c
aquí tenemos una idea interesante esto
es una proporción de voltaje a corriente
si esto fuera una simple ve entre y de
una resistencia simple esto sería igual
a r esta es una expresión de la ley de
ohm así que ahora tengo otra expresión
aquí para algo que está escrito en
términos de valores de componentes y
esta frecuencia natural ese y esto nos
va a llevar a una idea general de la
resistencia que se llama impedancia
y esto es una proporción y el símbolo
que usamos para representarla es z y
veremos esto durante los próximos videos
pues necesitamos revisar algunas cosas
para justificar lo que acabamos de hacer
en este vídeo así que repasaremos
algunas cosas en los siguientes vídeos
vamos a revisar algo de trigonometría en
particular senos y cosenos sus funciones
y lo que significan en especial cuando
son funciones del tiempo también vamos a
repasar la identidad de oyler que es
importante porque nos permite relacionar
el ala jx con el seno de x o coseno de x
y xi se acuerdan de lo que vimos cuando
resolvimos las ecuaciones diferenciales
esta forma a la j x siempre resultó ser
la solución más sencilla que encontramos
que a la algo
y si nos limitamos a usar senos y
cosenos como entradas vamos a necesitar
una forma de resolver estas ecuaciones
fácilmente y la identidad de hoy leer
nos permitirá encontrar esto cuando
veamos la identidad de oyler nos
encontraremos este número en todo
momento por lo que también repasaremos
los números complejos
estos son los tres temas que vamos a
repasar y después vamos a definir
algunas cosas como los factores
luego veremos la transformación que es
ese por el ri1 / s por c
los factores se refieren a cambiar el
coseno en algo que tiene un ángulo de
fase a ángulo
y finalmente vamos a resolver el
circuito
esta es la secuencia de los temas que
veremos en los siguientes vídeos para
poder usar esta poderosa técnica para
manejar circuitos complicados y hacer
que hagan lo que queremos